when you're saying it's not necessarily
that the middle one would have had Trump
yeah would he have needed the middle to
get reelected in 2024 in 2020
he would have needed roughly the same
percentage that Republicans tend to need
Trump suffered because their their he on
on the covet thing would he have gotten
reelected it's not only if covet didn't
happen Trump probably would have gotten
reelected I think if when kovitz started
instead of trump saying we have 15 cases
soon going to be zero do flu vaccines
work on covid what about bleach
injections all that stuff if instead of
that Trump said hey you know what we're
the United States we're going to deal
with this better than anybody else we're
making Maga masks and by the way 50
cents on every dollar will go you know
his his normal fundraising scams right
do the scams but do the Maga masks and
if he said we're going to be absolutely
the best on this thing he wins
[Music]
[Applause]